this morning I was checking out the
David Pakman show reddit discussion
forum you know it's amazing Pat we
started this discussion forum on reddit
at david pakman.com slash reddit with
fewer than a hundred of our viewers and
listeners we now have nearly four
thousand of our audience members who are
participating in political discussions
on reddit yep start at zero and work
your way up yeah I mean it's a normal
why would we start at 120 it doesn't
make we started at zero and obviously
it's been a process but that process as
Pat is pointing out has now led us to
almost 4,000 of our viewers I encourage
you to join us there and I wanted to
just quickly talk about some of the
interesting discussions taking place
there starting with a discussion about
my video on the left devouring itself
over Trump Russia if that's a topic that
is interesting to you and I know it
resonated with many in our audience go
to david pakman.com slash read it and
talk about it with other viewers and
there's not a unified front on that
subject matter I mean there are serious
disagreements among our audience very
controversial clip and regardless of
what side you're on in that discussion
there's going to be some things you hear
in that video that's going to upset you
probably yeah more than likely also from
our reddit discussion forum a post about
whether it's worth reaching out to the
other side and I've spoken pretty
extensively about how I feel that when
it comes to convincing trumpets with
facts it's just not worth it I believe
that you are way better off working to
get people to vote who did not vote last
election than you are trying to play
point counterpoint with Trump is to get
them to come to your side not everybody
agrees interesting discussion on our
reddit discussion forum going on now to
another discussion that was happening on
our reddit discussion forum a lot of
analysis of the handshake between Donald
Trump and Vladimir Putin at the g20
meeting in Germany and I was not the
only person who noticed Pat that Trump
did not pull any of his domineering
handshake games with Vladimir Putin in
fact quite the opposite he was fully the
beta male oh you know he put his hand up
when a body language expert over here
Trump has is palm facing up that which
exactly right misses kind of gesture
completely it's the equivalent
Pat's non feral cat exposing its belly
sure because it trusts Pat so much or
whatever a dog exposing its belly I
don't know but yeah Trump is doing the
same thing with his hand and an
interesting discussion of body language
happening there also on our reddit
discussion forum there was an
interesting reference made to something
that I read about actually yesterday
which is that if you want to think about
what the right thing is to do when you
hear that a foreign power might be
interfering in American politics when Al
Gore was given information that might
have been to the detriment of george w
bush he immediately got in touch with
the FBI and gave them everything not
exactly the approach of the trump
administration is it he had Bush's
entire debate talking points I mean how
valuable is that yeah and yet their
campaign did the right thing because I
don't think they wanted to get
themselves into potentially deep waters
there yes and well and we may learn that
actually they might have been able to do
it and get away with it because it
appears Trump might get away with it
himself we will see and lastly from our
reddit discussion forum a video about
the days and what it says is David and
Lewis discussed this before but toilet
paper doesn't make sense I use a bid day
and so should you
I I mean I couldn't possibly remember
every one of the 15,000 topics that
we've approached a broached on this
program over the years I don't remember
this conversation but I'm sure at some
point I've mentioned that in my birth
country of Argentina bidets are common
and it's often very very confusing many
Americans mistaking it for it's a second
toilet in the bathroom of a curry bag
and we don't you know have to go into
graphic detail about what's going on
here but an interesting video
nonetheless now I lived in an apartment
with for four months that had a bad day
was I was saying I was just kind of
scared and usually insane I didn't I
didn't use it you didn't you were scared
of it yeah I'm kind of think yeah I
guess when I've been to Spain there have
been four days as well but I don't think
I've seen them in France or belly I
don't think so none of the French word
that's true
that yeah why did why did I not see the
days in France that's a really strange
thing or maybe I just didn't notice it
anyway david pakman.com slash read it
whether it's the left devouring itself
or big
de humor it's all available at david
pakman.com slash reddit